انظر إلى ضيفي التالي يقول إن نشر
النتائج المؤقتة لبيان صحفي
ليس ممارسة علمية جيدة
ولا يساعد في بناء
ثقة الجمهور في اللقاحات كما يقول بدلاً من
ذلك ، يجب أن يأتي مع النشر الكامل لأبحاث
تمت مراجعتها من قبل الأقران
في مجلة علمية
، وهذا رأي
ريتشارد.
رئيس تحرير هورتون لمجلة لانسيت التي تعد
من أقدم وأشهر
المجلات الطبية الخاضعة لمراجعة الأقران في العالم ، انضم
إلي الآن
من لندن
إلى وجهة نظرك إذا كنا نتوقع
مرحبًا إذا كنا نتوقع أن نرى
منشورًا عن لقاح فيزا
في أي وقت قريبًا ،
حسنًا ، لا يمكنني إخبارك
بموعد نشر أعمالهم وبالطبع
لدينا لقاح أسترازينيكا أكسفورد
وفي الواقع هناك 11
لقاحًا في مرحلة متأخرة من التجارب السريرية ونحن
يجب أن تكون رؤية هذه النتائج قد تم
نشرها قبل
نهاية العام ، أنا متأكد من
أنك قد أوضحت نقطة جيدة جدًا ،
هذا الإعلان المالي من خلال
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بشكل فعال ، كما تعلمون للكثيرين
الأشخاص الذين شعرت بالاندفاع للحصول
على المرتبة الأولى في قائمة الانتظار عندما يتعلق الأمر
بسباق
اللقاح هذا وأنت تقول إن هذا أمر مقلق لأنك تقول
إنه وارن لأنه لا يمنح
الناس الثقة
، ورأيت بعد بضعة أيام
لقاح sputnik 5 الروسي  لقد
أصدروا بيانًا صحفيًا قائلين
إن لقاحهم كان فعالًا بنسبة 92 في المائة
لذا يبدو أننا في سباق الفضاء
ولكن بالنسبة للقاحات فيروس كورونا ،
فأنت تعلم أن القلق الأكبر هو
حركة مناهضة التطعيم
وهم يحرزون تقدمًا و  لذلك
علينا أن
نكشف عن النتائج حول هذه اللقاحات بأكبر
قدر ممكن من الدقة والعلم
حتى لا
نمنحهم أي مجال لإلحاق الضرر بالثقة
وهذا هو خطر العلم من قبل
الرؤساء ،
حسنًا ، لقد كان الرئيس ترامب
يضايق اللقاح ومن خلال  أو في وقت قريب من
موعد الانتخابات لفترة طويلة جدًا ، هل يمكن
أن يدعي أن هذا كان فوزًا
لإدارته بدافع الاهتمام ،
إنه بالتأكيد فوز للعلم الأمريكي
أه في الحقيقة هو فوز للعلم في
جميع أنحاء العالم كل
شيء  يستغرق الأمر من سبع إلى ثماني
سنوات للحصول على لقاح
من نقطة البداية الأولية في غضون 10
أشهر ، لدينا
أكثر من مائة لقاح مرشح في
مراحل مختلفة من الدراسة
وهو أمر غير مسبوق مثل كل شيء
آخر يتعلق بهذا الوباء ،
لكنه تكريم حقيقي للتعاون العلمي
بين الجامعات بين الجامعات الخاصة
قطاع بين شركات الأدوية الكبرى
لم نر شيئًا مثله من قبل
في التاريخ
، المرحلة التالية أه ستكون بالطبع
أه التصنيع والتوزيع
أم توزيع لقاح مثل هذا
كما أفهم أنه يمثل تحديًا كبيرًا ،
فقط اشرح ما إذا
كنت
ستفعل اللقاح  أه
غير مستقر نسبيًا ، وهذا يعني
أنه يجب الاحتفاظ بها عند درجة حرارة من 70
إلى 80 درجة تحت الصفر ، تكون درجة
حرارة الثلاجة العادية حوالي
4 درجات ،
لذا يمكنك أن تتخيل أنه
ليس هناك الكثير من
النسائم التي تعمل على هذا
المستوى  يجب أخذ اللقاح
في أه الصيدليات الرئيسية بالمستشفيات
حيث سيتم
توزيعه على الرقم الهيدروجيني.  الجيوش أو مراكز الرعاية الأولية
ولكن لديك 48 ساعة فقط حيث يمكنك
الحصول على اللقاح ليس في
درجات حرارة أقل من -70 ، لذلك سيتطلب شبكة
فعالة للغاية
للتوزيع ، لذا
سيكون الأمر صعبًا
، ولكنه سيكون
صعبًا